hello my name is jura i am a man
who lives on planet earth
[music]
I was born lived studied
lived and worked again and then everything
tired of
[music]
inside there is the most important thing in it
indoors the library here is this shelf with
books books
registered in the world library
book crossing people come here take
books and give their and so goes
books world electricity on the roof
is the solar panels train
stored in batteries and as
need I turn on the light which
glows and even the computer
for example computers i can through
Internet has been contacting to go global
net and engage on feast bookcrossing
to bake the center of any Russian house
Now it is preparing for this 5
gorgeous
food which I call pea and yes
what will be my very delicious today
already
when you live as usual
in the city of work that constantly need
think about tomorrow and here it is not
need to commit can not commit any
mistakes because it will all be
incorrigible and here it all makes sense
[music]